So let's outline what we want to do and
in the next segment we'll execute it.
We'll need to make our first request
to see how many results we get,
then parse the JSON that returns,
then determine how many pages
of results that ends up being.
We can then generate a random
number in that range
then use that number to make
a second request for a random page.
And finally,
repeat what we did previously and
get a random photo from that
random page of results.
In this chart, the steps are defined
in a way that suggests that each step
happens one after
the other without delay.
But remember, when we're working
with networking requests,
the requests don't complete immediately.
That's why we use a completion handler
to define what we want to happen
once a network request finishes.
It's like saying, I don't know when
the request will complete, but
run this code when it does.
Another added benefit is that while
the network request is being processed,
our app can continue running.
We describe this kind of request as
an asynchronous request, or asynchronous
task, because it gives us the ability
to define the behavior we want and
to defer its execution until
after something happens.
In this case,
after the request completes.
You can think of an asynchronous request
like putting a cake in an oven and
setting a timer to indicate when
the cake will finish baking.
While the cake is baking we can go do
other things like make frosting, but
as soon as the timer goes off, we need
to pull the cake out of the oven.
Pulling the cake out of the oven
is like our completion handler,
it's what we do as soon
as the timer goes off.
In the same way,
we want to make the second request only
after the first request finishes and
we've gotten a random page number.
In the second request we'll
define another completion handler
to handle getting a random photo
from the random page of results.
So you can see how to
achieve this flow of steps,
we're chaining together
asynchronous requests.
When one request finishes,
we'll move on to the next and so forth.
This kind of chaining of asynchronous
network tasks is a common occurrence and
there's some popular frameworks
out there for dealing with this.
We won't go into detail about
them in this course though but
if you're curious, you should check
out the links in the instructor notes.